one of my favorite scientists is
henry cavendish even though he was
uh part of the rich dukes
of devonshire
that family and incredibly rich he went
to cambridge to study
natural sciences or natural philosophy
as it's called but he had a very curious
condition in that he could hardly talk
to anybody so when it came to his fiverr
exam after three years of study he fled
cambridge rather than sit in front of
the examiners because he was petrified
of them
but he was one of the most brilliant
scientists of that 18th century in both
chemistry and physics
for chemistry he's noted because he
analyzed gases in the air he discovered
there was hydrogen
which is a a huge component of the
universe he called it inflammable air
so he put some acids in a container
dropped some metal like zinc into
hydrochloric acid and got the gas to
come off and then to show
it was flammable inflammable you could
set light to it he breathed it in and
blew it into a candle now do not do this
at home
because it blew up and took all the
hairs off his face he invented the idea
of electric potential before everybody
else and used to set electric currents
through his body to work out the
voltage's proportional current and he
measured the current by the degree of
agony he felt with the electrical
current this is not the normal sort of
person he couldn't talk to most people
he couldn't talk to women at all his
housekeeper would get a recipe for
something rather and he'd say no lamb
tonight leg of lamb and leave a note for
her he wouldn't say it he'd write it he
would dine in the evening with his
friends and he would talk to them but if
he didn't know somebody
and you wanted to ask him a question
apparently you had to go to the royal
society and he'd be in the room and
you'd address the room
this question about physics and you
postulate and if he felt in the mood he
replied to the room he was a very
strange man and yet he's absolutely
wonderful uh he invented hydrogen people
went up in hydrogen balloons and could
see the world from
through that perspective he did most of
the experiments quietly on his own
keeping his notebooks and it was only
after his death
and a persuasive campaign by
clark maxwell the famous maxwell of
maxwell's equations from cambridge
university that he actually got the
notebooks from the estate of the dukes
of devonshire and discovered after the
event that cavendish had discovered the
unit of capacitance discovered
dielectric constants he discovered
dalton's law of partial pressures he
discovered or written about coulomb's
law all before these guys had done it
and just left it unpublished in his
notebooks towards the end of his life
he did
a crucial experiment
which is represented by these lead balls
he lived in clapham common which is
nowadays a very poor part of london but
there it was quite fashionable and he
built his own
place
his library built somewhere else because
he didn't want anybody borrowing his
books from his house otherwise he would
have to ask the book back and he didn't
want to talk to them so his library was
four miles away
at the back of it he had a big garden
shed which might seem like the size of
my house
and in it he had two lead balls
like this
suspended from the ceiling only this is
not to scale this is
i mean lead balls
now the real problem is that he wanted
to measure the attraction between two
objects due to gravity
in other words there's a gravitational
attraction between you and me or between
me and this lead ball so he had to be a
long way away to look at the experiment
otherwise he'd interfere with it so he
had a an aperture a place where he
looked through and he put a telescope
out there and he stood outside in all
weathers
and he was in his 60s doing this staring
through the window to take his
measurements over a year
there's another set of lead balls inside
there this experiment really is very
difficult to get to work and a
technician is sorted apart so because he
got so frustrated and then right in the
middle there's a bit of glass
there's a mirror which is should be
suspended from a torsion wire so you'd
set it up like this in his shed
and you put it like that and this lead
ball would attract that lead ball and
this lead ball would attract this one
and so it would be pushed a little bit
this way and twist the wire and that
would be pushed a little bit that way
and the wire would twist and as the wire
twist the mirror which is dangling in
there would twist it a little bit and
light which comes in would be reflected
off at a slightly different angle and
all he had to do was measure the angle
he then
had to move it the other way around now
he didn't move this bit he moved the
lead balls around so that you had an
equal and opposite effect on the other
side
so instead of having you'd have that
configuration he had a
this is a very complicated technical
thing for the time
18th century we're talking about and he
put that
that way round and then it was pushed
the other way and you could then see the
displacement moreover you could measure
the period of oscillation of this and
from that get the all the properties of
the y the torsional constant and that
enabled him to measure big g the
gravitational constant to an accuracy
of one percent
and nobody improved on that for a
hundred years
he didn't describe it as that he
described it as though he was weighing
the earth he was calculating the mass
of the earth so that when you're
attracted to the earth through gravity
it's the product of
the mass of the earth this big
gravitational constant divided by r
squared the radius of the earth squared
which we normally know is acceleration
due to gravity
and that quantity
is essentially big
gene and he measured it and nobody could
do a clever experiment so he's a father
of physics experimental physics some of
the ideas of theoretical physics and a
lot of chemistry